tout le monde sauf Laurent Fontaine il
est là
et en fait j'ai pas compris je vois ce
monsieur qui dit voilà moi j'étais un
super ami de Jean-Pierre loufer des
études boss tu sais que j'avais jamais
entendu parler de lui cinq minutes après
la mort de mon papa il a appelé ma
marraine pour que ma mère fasse une
interview pour parler de la mort de mon
père mais même pas 5 minutes après que
ce soit déclaré tu vois d'accord donc
c'est quand même foot dire que le mec il
voulait autant surfer sur le buzz de la
mort de quelqu'un et dit que c'est moi
qui sort sur la mort de mon père bon lui
il avait dit en gros arrête sur twitter
fait des études boss et fais pas chier
oh c'est un peu ce que tu avais dit mais
c'est pas par contre la partie parce que
ouais je connais pas le loup c'est la
première fois que je la vois elle ne me
connaît pas de la télé
donc tact et j'ai aucun souci par
rapport à ça sauf que j'ai beaucoup
connu ton père bien avant que tu laisses
ma chérie parce que j'ai commencé une
émission très importante pour lui qui
savait combien ça coûte T91 et ça a duré
de nombreuses années il pense que si la
maman Nathalie t'a parlé de moi elle
doit très bien me connaître elle t'a pas
dit qu'elle ne me connaissait pas on a
même passé des vacances ensemble pendant
15 jours en Espagne etc avec ta mère ton
père des amis donc voilà tout ça est
dicté tout le monde sait que j'étais ami
avec Jean-Pierre sauf que j'ai beaucoup
moins vu Jean-Pierre à partir du moment
où il a été avec ta maman ça c'est vrai
voilà ça a été une période où
visiblement bon ouais ça c'est ça me
faisait moins on va dire et là-dessus
j'ai pas du joint à faire là du jugement
il se trouve que on ne fait réagir moi
en tant que mec qui a bossé avec
Jean-Pierre pernauto à une vidéo que tu
as fait il y a un nom on diffuse cette
vidéo ici et je te vois en larmes en
train de dire je sais que tu as 18 19
ans et en train de dire j'en peux plus
c'est trop dur c'est trop dur réponse
vous qui avez connu Jean-Pierre Renaud
vous voyez sa fille qui pleure vous en
pensez quoi j'ai deux filles qui
s'appellent John et Tamara qui ont
exactement ton âge qui font des études
comme toi et qui ne sont évidemment pas
sur Tik Tok ni influenceuse elles sont
consommatrices mais elles se mettent pas
en veulent être et j'espère que je pense
que vous n'entendrez jamais parler
d'elle elles sont pas les filles de on
sait jamais
ce titre qu'elle fasse autre chose donc
moi un moment dit j'ai 60 ans j'ai adoré
l'âge de de ton père évidemment voir ton
grand-père ce que je veux dire c'est que
quand on me demande ce que j'en pense
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je dise
d'autre à part ce que je conseillerais à
loup c'est de prendre son téléphone de
ouvrir son Tik Tok et de le fermer
pendant quelques mois si ça lui fait
tant de mal ça fait un pas contre toi je
vais plus établissait parce que c'est
pas le but du jeu c'était une réaction
comme il y a souvent télé et tu verras
ouais et du coup fallait éviter
c'est pas simple voilà mais après c'est
devenu communiquer de presse de Nathalie
Marquay qui il est alors le connaît tu
peux répondre c'est vrai que la télé
parfois pardon c'est caricatural c'est
15 secondes pour t'exprimer c'est brutal
déjà je suis désolé parce que j'ai très
mal parlé dans l'interview de Jordan de
luxe et donc je vous prie de m'excuser
monsieur fontaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est que vous avez dit à ce moment-là
et ce jour-là ou vraiment j'étais
vraiment plus bas que terre ok si je
faisais des vidéos je pleurais c'est
parce que tout le monde me demandait
comment j'allais et comment je faisais
pour sourire donc je me faisais si une
critique quand je souris autant montrer
quand je pleure parce que enfin autant
montrer
ma personnalité c'est mon choix et vous
n'avez pas à le juger du tout ce que
j'ai pas fait techniquement faire des
études buzz je suis en études
d'architecture d'intérieur
c'est que vous avez dit quand on
s'expose en gros sur les réseaux sociaux
faut s'attendre à se prendre des
insultes en fait je sais que c'est le
cas mais c'est tellement dommage d'avoir
la portée que vous avez et d'avoir des
personnes qui vous écoutent plutôt que
vraiment vous leur dites mais
insultez-la c'est normal
dans TPMP pour dire des bonnes choses je
te promets que dans TPMP dès que tu
ouvriras la bouche et que tu rentreras
chez toi si tu dis j'aime les gilets
jaunes du train d'insulter j'aime machin
j'aime les catholiques c'est que tu
parleras tu seras insulté on est jugé
tous les jours pour moi je dis pas ça
que pour moi je dis pas que par rapport
au jugement moi-même c'est bon moi j'ai
la force de tenir quand même un minimum
juste ce qui est dommage c'est de dire à
la télé au lieu de dire mais c'est bête
arrêtez de l'insulter elle a 19 parce
que j'avais 19 ans je dis ça ben non
mais c'est normal qu'elle soit
s'engueuler c'est envie de s'afficher je
trouve ça débile de faire ça pardon
c'est pas vous cadeau
c'est une lionne ta maman et c'est pour
ça que je l'adore ah bah le chat elle te
chope
elle a mis un petit un petit tweet on
sent que ça passait pas très bien entre
vous deux mais vraiment Nathalie entre
les deux mais voilà protège sa famille
c'est pas méchant ce qui savent lire je
te méprise de plus haut point de quel
roi permuter aventure sur ma fille qui
vit douloureusement la perte de son papa
tu l'as juste sans la connaître tu l'as
même jamais rencontré tu te trompes sur
son âge elle a pas 17 p19 et alors
qu'elle s'adresse à sa communauté sur
les réseaux sociaux tu oses dire va
faire des études boss et bien soit
disant proche de mon bar il défend
renseigne-toi votre vouloir faire du
buzz à la télé je t'emmerde gros con
voilà écoute elle a répondu c'est sa
fille si vous vous dites que vous étiez
un aliment père etc vous le connaissiez
tout ça tout ça dans ce cas-là est-ce
que pourquoi est-ce que ce jour-là moi
j'ai perdu mon père de semaine avant
dans peut-être deux mois avant je sais
plus vous êtes là et vous dites
n'importe quoi sur moi vous me
connaissez pas et vous me taquez alors
vous êtes censé être son ami et je dis
pas d'un bébé parce que parfois on dit
des bêtises je ne dis pas n'importe quoi
je peux te poser une question
extrêmement personnelle extrêmement
personnel dis-moi euh tu avais quoi ce
15 16 ans papa
est-ce que est-ce que tu allais sur ça
tombe depuis oui bah oui et tu vas
régulièrement ouais d'accord très bien
c'était une question moi j'arrive pas
mais si jamais tu as besoin que je
t'accompagne
et merci d'être avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]